i have this figure here you could call
it a rectangular prism and i want to
measure its volume and i'm defining my
my unit cube as being a one centimeter
by one centimeter by one centimeter cube
has one centimeter width one centimeter
depth one centimeter height and i will
call this this is equal to one cubic
cubic centimeter so i want to measure
this volume in terms of cubic
centimeters we've already seen that we
can do that by saying hey how many of
these cubic centimeters can fit into
this figure without them overlapping in
any way so if we had this you know in
our hands we could kind of try to go
around it and try to count it but it's
hard to see here because there's some
cubes that we can't see behind the ones
that we are seeing so i'm going to try
different tactics at it so first let's
just think about what we can observe
so we see that this one if we measure
its different dimensions it's width it's
two of the unit length
wide so it's two centimeters wide
it's four of our unit lengths we're
defining our unit length as a centimeter
it's four of our unit length high
so this this dimension right over here
is four centimeters
and it is three of our unit length deep
so this dimension right over here is 3
centimeters so i want to explore if we
can somehow use these numbers to figure
out how many of these cubic centimeters
would fit into this figure and the first
way i'm going to think about it is by
looking at slices so i'm going to take
i'm going to take a slice i'm going to
take this slice
right over here of
our original figure
and let's think about how we can how
using these numbers we can figure out
how many unit cubes were in that slice
well this is two centimeters wide
and it is four centimeters high
it is four centimeters high
and you might be saying hey sal you know
i could just count these things i could
get eight
eight eight squares here but what if
there was a ton there would be a lot
harder and you might realize well i
could just multiply the width times the
height that would give me the area of
this surface right over here and it's
only one deep so that also will give me
the number of cubes so let's do that
let's find the area here well that's
going to be two centimeters times four
centimeters
two centimeters times four centimeters
that gives us the area of this
and then if we want to find out the
number of cubes well that's also going
to be equivalent to the number of cubes
so we have eight square centimeters is
this area and the number of cubes is
eight and if we want the number of cubes
in the whole thing we just have to
multiply by the number of slices and we
see that we need
one two three slices this is three
centimeters deep so we're going to
multiply that times three
so we took the area of one surface we
took the area of this surface right over
here
and then we multiply it by the depth
that essentially gives us the number of
cubes because the area of this surface
gives us the number of cubes in a one in
a slice that is one cube deep and then
we would have to have three slices like
that so we would have to have this is
one slice we would have to have another
slice
another slice
and then another slice in order to
construct the original figure so 2
centimeters times 4 centimeters times 30
centimeters would give us our volume
let's see if that works out 2 times 4 is
8 times 3
is 24
24 let me do that in that pink color 24
centimeters cubed or i could say cubic
centimeters so that's one way to measure
the volume
now there's multiple surfaces here i
happen to pick this surface but i could
have picked another one i could have
picked this surface right over here and
done the exact same thing so let's pick
this surface and do the exact same thing
this surface is three centimeters
three centimeters by four centimeters
by four centimeters let me do that in
that blue color
color changing is always difficult
by 4 centimeters so its area is going to
be 12 square centimeters is the area of
this surface and 12 is also the number
of cubes that we have in that slice and
so how many slices do we need like this
in order to construct the original
figure
well we need it's two centimeters deep
this is only one centimeter deep so we
need two of them
we need two of them to construct the
original figure so we can essentially
find the area of that first surface
which was three times four
three times four
and then multiply that times
times the width times how how how many
of those slices you need so times two
and once again this is going to be 3
times 4 is 12 times 2 is 24. i didn't
write the units this first time but
that's going to give us the count of how
many cubic centimeters we have how many
unit cubes we can fit so once again this
is 24 cubic centimeters
and you can imagine you could do the
same thing not with this surface not
with this surface but with the top
surface
the top surface
is three centimeters deep
three centimeters deep
and two centimeters wide
two centimeters wide
so you could view its area or its area
is going to be three centimeters times
two centimeters so that area is let me
do the same colors
three centimeters times two centimeters
two centimeters which is six
square centimeters and that also tells
you that there's going to be six cubes
in this one cube deep slice but how many
of these slices do you need
well you have
this whole thing is four centimeters
tall and this thing is only one
centimeter so you need four of them so
that's two
two
three
three try and draw it as neatly as i can
three and four you're going to need four
of these so to figure out the whole
volume you have to take that and
multiply that
times 4 centimeters which once again 3
times 2 is 6 square centimeters times 4
centimeters is 24
24 cubic centimeters so any it doesn't
matter what order you multiply these in
you could view this take the ones area
of one side then multiply it times the
the depth or you could take the the
surface you have another height and
multiply it times the the the height or
the width or the depth and these are all
the scenarios but what it shows is it
doesn't matter what m what what order we
multiply
these three dimensions in you could view
it you could take the 2 times the 4
first and then multiply by the 3 or you
could take the 3 times the 4 first and
then multiply by the 2 and or you could
take the 2 times the 3 first and then
multiply by the four when you're
multiplying it doesn't matter what order
you're doing these in and so if you find
if you have a rectangular prism like
this and you know it's three dimensions
you know it's two centimeters wide three
centimeters deep and four centimeters
tall you could say hey the volume of
this thing the number of unit cubes the
number of cubic centimeters it can fit
is going to be two centimeters
two centimeters times four centimeters
times four centimeters times 3
centimeters which we've seen 3 times
already is 24 cubic centimeters